[Music]
when we're dealing with repeated notes
there are a few things to consider
depending on the context of the music
the first thing is whether or not we're
using different fingers or repeating the
same finger so for example the scarlatti
Sonata which is very famous for having
the repeated notes we're using four
three two one or three two one three two
one whatever combination suits you but
the key is that we're using different
fingers to play the same note side note
I like to use four three two one two one
because of the rhythmic implications I
don't like how it's divided into two
when I'm using three two one three two
one but I think both can work the thing
to note about the mechanics of repeated
notes is pretty simple you basically
need to get your fingers out of the way
so that the note the key can actually
reset before the next note is played
otherwise it'll get stuck which is a
common problem with repeated notes
[Music]
so this is a very obvious thing but when
you're using multiple fingers you have
an advantage because while you're
playing one note and you're getting it
out of the way the next note can be
ready to play right there
whereas when you're playing with one
finger and trying to repeat it regard
this is of how you're playing it there's
that time required to get it back to
position now this brings me to another
point so there's a big difference
between playing then though vertically
so with an up-and-down motion and
playing with curved fingers the thing to
note is that when you're playing up and
down even though it seems like you're
not moving as much you're actually
moving directions you're going up and
down whereas when you're playing with
the curved finger the change of
direction is softened because you're
using this circular motion so say that
you're repeating a note with three two
one
instead of thinking of it as a pecking
motion like this in that case maybe
you'll be using a wrist or your hands
more and you're inviting your hands to
tense up instead of that think of it as
a coil or some sort of spiral regardless
of what finger you're using so 4 3 2 3 -
even just one finger so this is a
measure from a piece that I wrote where
the top end requires a repeated note
with the fifth finger
[Music]
and in this case I think the type of
technique that you're using is very
similar to repeated octaves which I'll
probably do a video on separately
technique really comes from a very
relaxed wrist so even though visually it
may seem like my wrists aren't that
loose they are pretty loose compared to
my elbows which my whole forearm is
anchored from and they're locked into
place so my elbows are locked and my
wrists are relatively loose so now let's
go to the exercise
[Music]
so I wanted to create an exercise where
I'm challenging myself by using
different pairs of fingers for repeated
notes and in this case I settled with
tu-154 after that five four three two
and then I added in some intervals and
I'm just cycling through the circle of
this the most challenging thing for me
is when I'm repeating Black Keys just
because the surface area is much smaller
I have to be much more focused so of
course we don't want to neglect the left
hand so there's a left hand version as
well
[Music]
so just like with any other type of
technique or figure when we're
practicing repeated notes we can use
different methods such as rhythmic
practicing different groupings but the
thing to keep in mind is what you're
actually doing at the fingertips in
order to repeat the note and not get
caught up so whether we're playing
groups of two or with thoughted rhythms
or just slowly I'm going to focus my
attention on what I mentioned earlier
about the curved fingers and that
spinning type of motion almost like a
motor and also being very consistent
about the point of contact for each note
so I don't want to be repeating the note
in different areas of the keys just for
the sake of efficiency so I'll keep
these things in mind while practicing an
exercise like this or any other music
that requires repeated notes
[Music]
here's another repeated not exercise
that I've shown in one of my previous
videos that was taught to me by one of
my professors you just take one note and
you repeat it using all five fingers and
you'll be accenting every force note so
that you'll be cycling through accenting
with each finger you'll be basically
doing this while increasing the speed
gradually so anyway I hope you try these
exercises and let me know what you think
and as always I'll see you in the next
video bye
you